usted estuvo en afganistán usted conocía
en detalle o bueno una buena parte de la
estrategia que tenía eeuu y la alianza
de países allí en este país asiático que
falló
bueno fallaron muchas cosas desde el
principio estratégicamente hablando hace
20 años atrás cuando george wood
terminó la misión contra terroristas
terminó la lucha contra al qaeda contra
los árabes estaban allí de huéspedes de
los pastos de los talibán el cce se
embarcó en un
erróneamente ingenuamente en esta misión
the nation building de rehacer la nación
afgana imagen y semejanza eeuu
democratizar las
constituciones políticas militares
hechas a las copias de un país
occidental y eso obviamente estaba desde
el principio ya condenado al fracaso
entonces era una misión imposible una
misión es dificilísima contra marea
hacer eso pero a pesar de todas esas
dificultades en 20 años y a pesar de las
miles de vidas perdidas de los miles de
millones de dólares invertidos en lo que
de verdad le puso el fin a esta aventura
este experimento una decisión terrible
trágica de joe by de abando a nuestros
aliados afganos a su suerte usted dice
que fue un fracaso esta operación de dos
décadas allí también es un fracaso
entonces para la diplomacia para la
estrategia de occidente y para eeuu en
general y le parece a usted que entonces
deja un terreno libre para que rusia y
china- consideren afganistán para
posicionarse allí dado que lo consideran
ya como una zona de influencia
por supuesto ya china se está moviendo
ya china entabló relaciones diplomáticas
con los talibanes ya está abriendo una
carretera y vías de comunicación desde
el territorio del chino al territorio
afgano directamente a lo que nunca había
pasado y ya pues obviamente estaban
negociando contratos para explotar la
minería de afgana y afgana y obviamente
pues rusia también se va a mover al
terreno diplomático para adjuntos china
y rúsia mantener su influencia sobre
sobre el software asiático y obviamente
pues ellos van a llenar el vacío que
deja eeuu pero pero hay que ver a nivel
estratégico esto es un desastre para
eeuu no solamente porque han fracasado
20 años de esfuerzos miles y miles y
miles de millones de dólares invertidos
allí clara tratando de crear unas
instituciones democráticas
parecidas a las acciones tales y las
vidas que han perdido pero ahora también
el prestigio de eeuu que abandona a sus
aliados eso pues es un golpe brutal a
eeuu señora ledo rápidamente cree usted
que la comunidad internacional subestimó
el poder de talibán
eeuu específicamente es subestimar el
poder de talibán creyó que el ejército
este vi que habíamos creado nosotros con
20 años de esfuerzo iba a ser suficiente
realmente no lo ha sido no tuvo ni la
fortaleza ni tuvo el apoyo logístico y
de estado de eeuu y por eso cayó